it's seven o'clock in the UK 10 at night
in Turkey in Syria as those countries
deal with the aftermath of deadly
earthquakes
at least 2 600 people are killed with
many more injured as buildings collapse
with crashing Force
[Applause]
it's the biggest disaster in more than
80 years according to turkey's president
with devastation along a major fault
line
we'll keep across those rescue efforts
live throughout the evening
in Syria towns and cities at the center
of the country's decade-long Civil War a
hit including regions with thousands of
refugees
as we reach the entrance of the building
it collapsed totally on us God saved us
and a wooden door fell on us which saved
us
the promises of international aid for
The Rescuers with more than 40 countries
including the UK pledging help
[Music]
good evening and welcome to a Sky News
special program on the devastating
earthquake on the border of turkey and
Syria at least 2 600 people have been
killed a number that's expected to rise
in the coming days coming up we've got
our lead reports with the latest from
both turkey and Syria from our
correspondence in Istanbul and the
Middle East we'll speak to the eu's
spokesperson on humanitarian Aid in
crisis management about how Europe is
responding our science editor will
analyze exactly what happened to make
this earthquake quite so devastating and
we'll speak to a leading seismologist
too and much more to come but first
let's take you through where exactly the
impact took place the first earthquake
with a magnitude of 7.8 struck at 17
minutes past four in the morning Turkish
time about 20 miles from the city of
gaziantep close to turkey's border with
Syria and a depth of six miles dozens of
aftershocks followed within minutes the
strongest measuring 6.6 nine hours later
at 1 24 PM local time a second Quake
measuring 7.5 happened 62 miles north at
pazuchuk in the Cameron morass Province
the worst affected areas were along this
tectonic line the East antolian vault
which is similar in size to the San
Andreas Fault in California our Europe
correspondent Siobhan Robbins is in
Istanbul and less than 24 hours since of
course the news of this story reached us
all and sadly the toll keeps Rising
a really dark day for both turkey and
Syria at least 2 600 people have been
confirmed dead the rescue efforts have
been going on throughout the day it's
dark now it's cold there's rain there's
snow temperatures are dropping in some
places below zero degrees just hampering
the efforts this is the story of the day
in Turkey
in southern turkey buildings crumble
like sand
[Music]
obliterated by some of the worst
earthquakes in a century
[Applause]
the first struck Before Dawn as the
country slept
the impact captured on a shop CCTV
shaking for around 90 seconds
thank you
the terror and scale of the damage
revealed with the light
the number trapped beneath the rubble is
unknown
the death toll is rising and the
aftershocks keep coming
up
a second 7.6 Quake rocked the center of
the country making the rescue efforts
even more dangerous
[Music]
magnitude and he did cause uh a certain
extra damage not just only hampering the
rescue airports because I did see on my
way this is my second visit here some of
the buildings that were uh that looked
fine before were also damaged
the earthquake was not only powerful but
shallow widespread destruction without
warning
a force so intense it wiped out history
in seconds
this 2 000 year old castle among the
wreckage
at 4 17 am we experience the worst
disaster of the century since the 1939
Erza Jan earthquake
the earthquake whose epicenter was in
parachuk in caraman marash and had a
magnitude of 7.7 as per the latest
estimates was felt in a very broad
region
survivors are being found here a child
is pulled from the rubble
the next 48 hours are critical for
saving as many lives as possible
dangerous for those still trapped rain
sleet and snow are slowing down Rescuers
with temperatures expected to drop below
zero in the coming hours
dozens of countries have already pledged
Aid the UK is sending 76 search and
rescue Specialists with dogs and
equipment
for survivors time is now the greatest
threat
well Aid is coming those UK teams
expected to arrive this evening but this
has been called an apocalyptic quake and
the fear is that in the end the death
toll could rise as high as 10 000.
thank you
now around the world governments are
scrambling to offer what Aid they can
with teams of rescue Specialists already
arriving in Turkey but also hit was
neighboring Syria where the pitcher is
far more complicated already devastated
by a civil war getting relief where it's
needed will prove the biggest challenge
a warning that our Middle East
correspondent Alistair bunkel's report
includes pictures of one young victim
being treated for his words
Syria has suffered more than a decade of
Civil War and is completely unprepared
to deal with something like this
many of the buildings were already
heavily damaged in the conflict or
poorly built they would have stood no
chance in an earthquake this strong
people rushed outside into the dark
early morning frightened and with
nothing but the clothes they wore on
their back
um
foreign
the Syrian Civil Defense better known as
the white helmets were on the ground
immediately they're used to dealing with
the aftermath of airstrikes but this has
left them overwhelmed
a
modifications
foreign
s to pull survivors from the rubble
a small girl was saved limb but alive
[Music]
they were rushed to hospitals already
struggling under the weight of War
our colleague in Northwest Syria filmed
these pictures of the Wounded being
treated a child cries with pain as
Medics Stitch a wound in his head
Syria
urgently needs International help but
getting Aid into rebel-held areas will
be a huge challenge in itself
we are ready to provide support to the
people there we are looking at all the
needs wherever they are that we do not
look at the politics and we would like
to see the politics put aside and
facilitate the access of the U.N and
humanitarian Partners here
from Aleppo to access those people who
need help
some streets have been totally flattened
Rescuers on their hands and knees shout
through small gaps to see if anyone is
alive
cranes are being used to pull heavy
blocks of concrete from the top of piles
that were once homes
millions of syrians are already refugees
from the years of fighting communication
lines were already patchy and there are
few International organizations
operating on the ground there the full
Grim story of what has happened in
Northwest Syria is yet to be revealed
Aleister bunkel Sky News
now British eight teams are due to
arrive in Turkey this evening the eu's
also activated its EU civil protection
mechanism before those teams arrive
Turkish relief teams are already in
Action a lot of the rescue effort has
been focused around dire back here south
east turkey where many buildings
collapsed we are joined now by the eu's
spokesperson for humanitarian Aid and
crisis management to balash uivari thank
you so much for for joining me uh this
evening
um first and foremost what is the view
in the EU of this uh this tragedy
so there's a very very difficult day
good evening we have been working very
hard uh to respond to this natural
disaster
hitting uh turkey and and Syria
um in the early hours of the morning we
received a activation request from
Turkey for the EU civil protection
mechanism this is a mechanism that can
be used to face the consequences of a
natural or man-made disasters since then
we've been working very hard here in
Brussels through our crisis Management
Center to mobilize the help that is
needed on the ground this meant in the
initial hours of the day search and
rescue teams now in the course of the
day we have managed to make available
nearly 20 such teams from 50 new member
states so more than half of daily member
states have responded to this Turkish
request and also Montenegro and these
teams are on the way in fact some of
them for example the Bulgarian Romanian
Hungarian teams are already on the
ground contributing to the rescue to
Assets in turkey and as we go into the
night and the morning hours more and
more teams will reach the country now as
a second step now we are looking at
Emergency Medical Teams this is also a
Turkish request we already have a few uh
proposals for example Spain has a team
ready to go so you can expect more such
teams as well getting to Turkey in the
coming hours and days but our viewers
will have seen flashed up on the the
bottom of the screen the the sad
development that we're updating uh our
death toll estimate from over 2 600 now
sadly to over 2 700 people just wanted
to to mention that
um in terms of the coordination of this
I mean it'll be a huge task on the
ground in Turkey to coordinate all these
different teams
um from different different countries
are you able to help in that effort
given that you yourself are providing uh
teams from so many different in
individual countries
that is exactly what we are doing we are
deploying as we speak uh about a dozen
of colleagues um indeed specifically to
help the coordination efforts giving
that given the fact that um there are a
large number of countries so in addition
to the 50 new member states there are
many many uh countries from all over the
globe that provide assistance so we
would like to play uh an important role
we have a lot of experience in
coordinating uh help in disaster
situations so the colleagues on the
ground will certainly make a major
contribution in this regard and and and
some of the actions you mentioned so far
was that just relating to Turkey or or
does that include Syria too or is it
slightly a different a different case of
how you may or may not be able to help
to Syria
many kinds of Syria here in a bit of a
different context and that is because uh
Syria has not activated the EU civil
protection mechanism this is not
something that the EU can do we can only
respond to a a request put in by a a
member state or any country around the
world so in the case of Syria we have
not received as such a requests however
we are an extremely important actor in
the country when it comes to
humanitarian Aid we have a number of
humanitarian partner organizations that
are on the ground in Syria that we have
been financing for for a number of years
already just to give you some figures
since 2011 the EU has provided 27
billion Euro for humanitarian purposes
in Syria and just last year we made
available 150 million euro
um and and what we hear we have had
conversations with our partner
organizations on the ground but we hear
from them is that they are refocusing
their activities as we speak on the
region which has been hit which has been
struck by the earthquake and that's
where they are providing a range of a
range of activities a range of services
be it in terms of water and sanitation
support but also they are providing
blankets shelter and hygienic items so
they are very much involved in the
country and we are of course standing
with them and if need be we can also
mobilize additional humanitarian support
to specifically help in this context and
whether it's turkey or Syria what's
communication like on on the ground are
you confident you will be able to
coordinate things or help coordinate
things
we have a lot of experience in in facing
man-made or natural disasters uh over
the past years we have been working in
the context of many many earthquakes uh
tsunamis or um for example the explosion
in the port of Lebanon so um the
department that I'm part of is is very
much experienced that I'm confident that
we can be we can be bringing this
expertise uh to the benefit of the of
the people on the ground and clearly
this is still 24 hours since This
Disaster uh unfolded and uh the
immediate work at hand uh you know
working working through some of the
rubble and hopefully finding some
survivors what about in the days and
weeks ahead how does the relief efforts
and support that you can offer change
indeed so right now we are focused on
helping the first respond this we are in
an immediate crisis management phase
that's the reason why for now we have
focused on making available search and
rescue teams and as I said as a second
stage we'll be looking at Emergency
Medical Teams which will slowly be
arriving as well in in Turkey in the
coming hours and and days and of course
if I look at the medium term then uh the
emphasis will be on on reconstruction
and again this is also an area where the
EU has a lot of a lot of expertise so
once we get to that stage of course we
will be looking into this situation in
great detail and we will see how we can
help in terms of the Reconstruction
efforts as well but thank you so much
for joining me
thank you
this is Sky News tonight and coming up
turkey may be used to responding to
earthquakes but we'll discuss why this
disaster presents particular problems
for the relief effort
[Music]
welcome back turkey is a country fairly
used to dealing with the aftermath of
earthquakes but this disaster has been
particularly devastating let's discuss
why Sir Mark lowcock who served as the
United Nations under Secretary General
for humanitarian Affairs and emergency
relief coordination until 2021 joins me
now so Mark thanks so much for for
joining me um but before we dive into to
some of those factors I just teased
um talk to me about how you're feeling
about the the death toll we just
mentioned it's risen from 2600 to over 2
700. should we sadly expect it to
continue to rise from here
well that is the pattern of these things
unfortunately as more information comes
in there's more basically become
accessible it does become clear that
larger numbers of people have died I've
seen one credible estimate of what this
may reach which is an estimate made by
the U.S geological center I think about
ten thousand is much too early to say
whether it will give that order of
magnitude but I think we should be aware
that the numbers will end up
substantially bigger than they are now
especially actually in the places where
we're not seeing in any of the footage
at the moment which are the affected
parts of Northern Syria which is where
many of the most vulnerable people may
end up being
well and that never has uh timing been
so unwelcome our producer just
confirming Sky News can report the death
toll's now risen to over three thousand
um very much speaking to to that point
we were just discussing I I want to get
into Syria in just just a moment uh but
but more broadly before that you've
worked on many disasters uh of this sort
of ilk in in the last couple of decades
what are the factors that uh can can
lead to a higher death toll relative to
a comparable scale earthquake is this
just such a a forceful earthquake that
the death call was going to be high or
is it down to quality of buildings or
infrastructure or just bad luck
well I mean the first thing to say is
the world has got a lot better actually
over recent Decades of dealing with
these kinds of problems I remember an
earthquake in Mexico in 1985 killed 10
000 people and not that dissimilar
earthquake in Mexico which I dealt with
in 2017 took the lives with just a few
hundred and that was because of better
search and rescue better building
standards and so on and that's been a
patent across much of the world so the
bases were earthquakes which of course
you get no notice of an earthquake
um it makes it quite different to most
humanitarian disasters the places where
they do most damage are the places which
are highly populated with weak
infrastructure and poor Services now
gaziente and that part of turkey where I
last was about three years ago just
developed hugely over the last 25 years
there's a lot of infrastructure a lot of
high-rise there have been questions
about the standards of it it's a
relatively well developed place though
and and that is why you're seeing that
there is a very energetic quite well
coordinated First Response system
playing out in parts of Syria where this
has affected people I think that it may
not be the same story so what determines
the scale of the problem death hole
injury and so one is where it happens
and the underlying conditions in those
places how well developed they are how
well prepared they are
so touch on Syria for us as you've
already mentioned uh it's going to be
much harder to see effective relief
efforts reach there quickly
um what other factors should we be
watching out for
well
the first
first millions of people in Northwest
Syria including Millions who have fled
the fighting during the Civil War away
from the Syrian military authorities are
basically encamped in very rudimentary
conditions both in the southern part of
Italy across the border nearest to
gaziente but a little bit further north
of that as well which may be the place
is worth affected in Syria by this
earthquake
um
there's little access to the
International Community to those people
from Damascus and the Syrian authorities
view them as the opposition and don't
really want help to get to them so the
international community's access comes
across the border from Turkey the un's
only allowed to use one border crossing
now the Turks can use more border
crossings but that does constrain things
but the other thing is that of course
turkey's priority will rightly be its
own citizens in its own country and
after that probably Syrian refugees who
were in turkey and so those people in
Syria will not be high up the list of
priorities
um so I am really worried about the
prospect for helping them it is a good
thing that Aid agencies have a lot of
Staff already in kaziantech running that
cross-border operation but I hope the
money that comes in for the relief
operation enough of it is targeted at
those people in in Syria because I think
they'll need it most we just spoke
moments ago to to a senior EU official
in this regard and we've been talking
about how the foreign secretary informed
us of the number of search and rescue
teams the UK is sending how much can
they deliver in the days ahead I'm sure
no Miracles but uh can they deliver uh
encouraging results
yes search and rescue does make a
difference in that Mexico 2017
earthquake I mentioned we were able to
mobilize 500 people from around the
world deep specialists in 27 countries
and they didn't make a difference I
think what we'll see is that the
international contribution to their
search and rescue ought to say dozens or
scores of lives possibly a few more but
it will only
um that'll only be a useful thing to do
for a few days and most of the life say
will be those safe by the people we can
see on your screen now Turkish First
Responders and turkeys institutions but
the international contribution is useful
um and should quickly be followed by
more help with emergency medical
assistance
um medical supplies and also shelter
um getting the Power and Water Systems
up and running again some people need
food very quickly there's the
requirement will move from search and
rescue into those other things so Mike
lowcock thanks so much for joining us
this is Sky News tonight and still to
come we'll look at the exact moment the
earthquake hit and find out what made
this one quite so devastating and speak
to someone who witnessed it firsthand
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Sky News and a special program on the
earthquake in turkey and Syria at least
3 000 have been killed and thousands
injured after a 7.8 magnitude earthquake
struck turkey Syria and Lebanon
president erdogan called the disaster
the country's worse since the 1930s with
British and European Aid on the way
we're bringing you the latest on the
rescue efforts throughout the
well here's what we know about that
earthquake the 7.8 magnitude Quake
struck at about 417 in the morning and
was centered near the city of gazientep
as search and rescue operations were
underway a second earthquake with a
magnitude of 7.6 struck Central turkey a
few hours later more than three 2 800
buildings have collapsed in turkey and
hundreds of people are believed to be
buried under the rubble the death toll
has crossed 3 000. it's one of the most
powerful earthquakes turkey has ever
experienced but there are several
factors that meant it was particularly
devastating our science editor Tom
Clarke has this analysis
the initial earthquake struck overnight
on the East Anatolian fault line that
runs through southern turkey and it's
7.8 on the magnitude scale is by far the
largest in the region in living memory
this map shows the worst of the shaking
in red tracing the fault line as it runs
close to the city of gaziantep but the
power of the Quake meant it affected
hundreds of other cities and towns in
the region see here where orange and
yellow lines show significant shaking in
Syria and Tremors felt as far as Cyprus
then there are aftershocks shown here in
Orange are the typical Quakes
diminishing in magnitude and frequency
along the fault line over the morning
but what makes this event so unusual is
that nine hours after the initial Quake
a huge 7.5 magnitude Aftershock almost
as strong as the first happened here 100
kilometers to the North in Cameron
Morris province as well as being violent
both the initial quake and that
Aftershock were relatively shallow in
the Earth's crust 18 and 10 kilometers
deep respectively the closer to the
surface the more damage a quake will
cause
turkey and Northern Syria are vulnerable
to earthquakes they sit at the junction
of four tectonic plates with fault lines
along their margins these latest Quakes
occurred on what's called a strike slip
fault the Anatolian plate is being
pushed westwards at a rate of about two
centimeters a year by the northward
movement of the Arabian plate and it was
the sudden release of this stress that's
built over many decades that caused this
disaster
and in geological terms it's one of
turkey's worst the town of Izmit was
shaken by a 7.6 magnitude earthquake in
1999 killing more than 17 000 but not
since 1939 as there been an earthquake
as violent where more than 30 000 people
died in a 7.8 magnitude Quake around
ersen can
but crude measures of geological Force
don't tell us much about the human scale
of this tragedy it will be days before
that becomes clearer
let's get more now uh on the seismology
with Remy bosu head of the Euro
Mediterranean seismological Center thank
you so much for joining us uh Remy I
mean first uh just Gage for us we heard
a bit about it there
um how abnormal this Quake was how
strong it was at 7.8 and then in
particular followed by that second 7.6
uh Quake just a few hours later
7.8 is a very large magnitude especially
in this sort of settings typically
um you have these type of earthquakes in
what we call subduction zones so along
the Pacific the Pacific Ocean for
example when the subtraction when the
plateaus any plates goes below the
continents it was the case for example
for the toku earthquake in Japan in 2011
so for this type of settings it is close
to the maximum we have observed it is
the highest magnitude uh observed in
Turkey since 1930
and it has broken uh the the the default
of a 200 kilometers length so the
rupture has broken over 200 kilometers
and in all these area the people were
subject to the people and the buildings
were subject to very high and long
shaking
and and Tom Clark was just explaining to
us about the aftershocks whether it was
the small uh more typical aftershocks
which all appeared seemingly uh close to
or along the fault line uh or the more
Standalone 7.6 on the on the scale uh
after shocking in the middle of turkey
talk us through how normal or abnormal
uh that those factors are
yeah so typically what we observe
traditionally observe is that we have a
main shock and then we have aftershocks
which follow along the same retro Zone
the lower in magnitude and uh they are
close in space to the previous structure
here the second earthquake the one of
this morning 7.6 approximately is nearly
as big as the first shock and it is on
the second fault system so if you look
at the aftershocks so as it was clearly
shown in your
previously the the first shock was along
the Southeastern anatomyal Anatolian
fold and the second one is on the second
fault which is basically 100 kilometers
and which Trends uh east to west so it
is totally different system so basically
it is not an Aftershock it is a second
shock which has been triggered by the
first one so this is unusual we call
this a sequence of earthquake there are
settings where we observe them you may
remember in 2016 in Italy we had several
magnitude six notches
earthquakes but they were magnetic six
and magnitude six and magnitude 7.8 are
not comparable they are just uh when you
increase the magnitude by one you
increase the energy released by a factor
of 32 so that's a very very different
cases and and
possible now as we approach 24 hours
since the first one that we're in the
clear there'll be no more aftershocks
talk me talk me through the likelihood
of how it rises and Falls uh further
further potential Quakes in in the short
term
unfortunately there will be aftershocks
in the coming days in the coming weeks
the Aftershock activity has been very
high we had the magnitude 6.7 I think 20
minutes after the first truck last night
so it has been very high we had probably
200 aftershocks above magnitude for
today so it's basically as uh the ground
has been shaking nearly continuously
what is nice with the aftershocks if I
can say so is that the the rate decrease
exponentially so it decreased very fast
with time but still it decreased fast
but it will it will last for weeks and
months so the rate is going to decrease
the rate has decreased already it should
keep decreasing but we you we will still
observe magnitude 5 magnitude uh even
more than five in the coming days and
weeks but their frequency will be lower
and lower
um you you study this area
um fairly closely were there any signs
ahead of it that this was coming
no
unfortunately we are totally unable to
predict uh you know in in Turkey what
has been expected by the seismologist is
a large earthquake typically the same
size and the one we had last night just
below just uh close to Istanbul in the
mamarasi we expect to magnets at 7.6
there has been many studies which shows
that it should happen
um the studies were made like 10 years
ago and it is supposed to happen in the
next three decades so but we have no
clue whether it will happen today or
whether it will happen uh in 20 or 30
years time so last night I I first
thought it was the one in Istanbul so we
were proved wrong again so we cannot
predict earthquakes so we really have to
make sure that our building can
withstand the shaking it's the only way
that we can protect because we know that
we are totally unable to get to
prediction which will allow us to
evacuate cities before an Earthquakes
track
Remy bosu really very interesting thank
you so much for joining us
you're welcome
now the scale of the challenge facing
relief teams entering the country is
vast are data and forensics team has
been looking at the worst of the damage
to infrastructure and buildings earlier
Skies Tom Cheshire spoke to a rescue
worker from the humanitarian response
charity serve on
there's a huge amount of videos coming
out because of the scale of Devastation
we're going to be taking a forensic look
at them in the search and rescue effort
with AB from serve on so what we want to
show you is some of the extent of the
damage by looking at what it was before
this is escender and it's a city uh in
the southwest of Port City and this is
what it looked like before the
earthquake struck I want to take you
into Google Street View here in the
middle of the city more or less you can
see it is a built up place but I want
you to focus on a couple of buildings
here this distinctive uh skyscraper
there this Tower block there
um and then if you look over here we've
got this apartment block now this is
what it looks like after the earthquake
start we can play that video you can see
those are the three tower blocks and
that block simply doesn't exist anymore
as the video goes on you'll see go
further to the right again that was the
apartment block we saw before when
you're looking at this and you see a
city-wide Devastation like this how do
you approach it is there sort of triage
process to it triage is the right way to
put it if you imagine there's maybe 10
or 15 teams on the ground
um how do we organize where they go so
we've got to look at the at the
buildings and and as you said some
buildings have collapsed and some
haven't and it could be right or right
the way across the city so we need to
figure out which buildings have got the
most likelihood of finding casualties in
them when you mention that some
buildings collapse and someday this is a
video from another part of turkey it's
not the same city but we look through
this you'll see these buildings are
standing and then over here that's
coming down as the rescue effort is
ongoing I think people watch them think
why is that building completely fine and
why is this building coming down
there's a number of reasons why why that
can happen one obviously is just pure
luck there's there's no way we can be
predictable about an earthquake or where
or where it's going to hit it doesn't
always hit the whole area
um it could be luck it could be down to
um the quality of the building and
actually it could even be that one
building was was holding up another
building so when one goes the other
one's still the domino effect I think
the quality of the building I mean
that's obviously going to be something
people focus on afterwards and where and
whether those standards were met but
just in the here and now you know this
is the search and rescue effort you're
shortly going to Turkey you're going to
be taking part in this when you're going
out there and you come across these
scenes if you're there on the scene what
are the first things you're thinking
about as a rescue worker but the rescue
worker the first thing that we think
about is is speed of getting of
casualties out
um they could have been in there for 15
or 16 hours by the time we get we by the
time we get to them so it's how do we
get them out but how do we get them out
safely you can see all of these uh
volunteers uh helping out here we must
make sure that that we're not putting
them in any in any further danger and
how do we get the casualty out without
putting them in any further further
danger either AB from servon thank you
very much best of luck in Turkey from
all of us there's going to be lots more
videos coming out given the scale of the
devastation we'll be working to verify
them analyze them forensically bringing
the latest over the coming days
now in the moments are immediately
following uh the earthquake rescue teams
began their work in Syria the Civil
Defense Force had been providing relief
this is them at work in Afrin uh this
group known as the white helmets was
formed to provide medical evacuation and
urban rescue amidst the countries uh of
course uh Civil War they were also at
work in idlib searching for survivors in
a string of collapsed buildings uh we're
joined Now by oreche nezodin director of
action AIDS Arab region and thank you so
much for joining me this evening just uh
let us know exactly what action Aid does
typically in in the region outside of
natural disasters like this
thank you for having me tonight uh so as
action8 we uh we have been present since
mid-2000s in in the region uh we work
mainly uh apart from the humanitarian uh
responses to the various crisis we do
work on uh Youth and uh women uh uh
development uh and women's rights in in
the region mainly working in Jordan and
Lebanon uh in Syria and Tunisia these
are the main areas uh uh where we work
we work on women economic as well as
political empowerment and on on young
people also Civic and political uh
participation and I mean majority of the
work unfortunately in the past I guess
seven to ten years has been focused on
responding to the humanitarian crisis in
uh um in Lebanon in in Syria we've
worked also uh briefly in in other
countries like Yemen as well
um and I I mean if we focus perhaps on
on Syria for a moment firstly I I very
much hope all of your team members and
contacts are are safe
are you able now to connect with
specific uh relief teams that are more
focused on helping in an earthquake
because of your knowledge and contacts
on the ground
so we have
a truck of local partners that we've
been working with for the past for the
past couple of years unfortunately uh
some of our
partners staff members have not been
accounted for uh up until now we were
since the morning uh uh with them on on
the phone trying to to communicate like
majority are are are safe but there are
but some have not been accounted for and
neither their families
um to be honest also because a lot of
our partners we work with North and are
in Northwest Syria and they run the
operation from Southern turkey so they
have been affected uh uh double like
both of their of their offices so it is
it has been really really hard to uh to
to connect because of the uh uh cut and
the communication uh up until the last
two hours we've been able to establish a
contact uh groups of volunteers from our
partners have been trying to respond to
their is in Northwest Syria and and
mainly in italypt and atlib governorates
and we are working with them closely to
understand the immediate needs uh so
that we can deploy resources to support
and this in this crisis well we we
really very much hope that you are able
to uh to reconnect with with all of your
team members uh in in the days ahead
um to those that you are in touch with
uh what is the sort of of help that they
are saying the Regions they're in uh is
needed perhaps help that is has not yet
been offered or provided from elsewhere
yeah so uh inside in Northwest Syria the
main the immediate thinks that they have
they have shared or uh needed or uh uh
like ready to eat like food items uh uh
shelter temporary shelter is is much
needed because as you know people have
been uh on the street since uh uh early
hours in the morning when the earthquake
occurred uh uh then there is a need of
heating of course uh Hospital uh medical
facilities need to be uh uh like uh
equipped equipped more and they need
more uh uh more support at um at that
level this is what has been assured
another thing that is very important
that was noted by our partner from Syria
is the absence of equipment to remove
that Deborah so uh previously they have
been supported a bit like in the past
years whenever a crisis occurs in the
Northwest part of Syria sometimes turkey
provided this kind of support like
machinery and meant to remove the
adapters but currently this because of
the crisis in in Turkey some like one of
our partners was saying to me that they
are like volunteers are using like their
hands and very basic tools to to uh to
remove the debris so this is much needed
and heavy machinery is required in order
to be able to rescue uh the the people
from under the robots which we know is
the most important thing in the upcoming
hours is to search and rescue uh and
rescue people so that has been what has
been shared to uh up up till now we are
following up closely to see if there are
any other emerging needs so that we can
able to be able to provide and and
respond to it immediately
Russia thank you so much for joining us
this evening
thank you
you're watching Sky News and still to
come why this earthquake turned some
buildings to Rubble but others remained
unscathed
welcome back we've been discussing uh
the death toll let's now touch a little
bit on the physical damage and a lot of
turkey's relief effort has been focused
here in Adana now while money buildings
withstood the initial earthquake and
Powerful aftershocks others were turned
to rubble and in uh also in Turkey
probably the most shocking footage of
the day was of this residential block it
took just 10 seconds
for the entire block to crumble wow well
joining us to discuss this Professor
David Alexander from the University
College London's Institute for risk and
disaster reduction thanks so much for
for joining me Professor I mean first a
broad question when you have an
earthquake of this magnitude not to
mention uh such a a high magnitude uh
Aftershock just a few hours later is it
very hard almost impossible to to reduce
the risk of buildings collapsing like
this or not
it is utterly possible the reason why
there is a disaster is rather different
to the reason why there is an earthquake
what has happened here is that we have
suddenly revealed
shoddy building now Turkish building
codes have been revised five times in
the last 55 years and they are pretty
good or at least the codes of 2018 are
however a mixture of Failure to observe
the codes failure to enforce them
ignorance and Corruption means that
buildings collapse because they are
badly built this morning the U.S
Geological Survey issued a map that
shows that there is only one tiny area
in a vast range of land where
well-engineered buildings will be likely
to collapse it's an area of about four
square kilometers and yet we see very
widespread collapse and this is simply
because buildings are not built to any
recognizable reasonable code and
unfortunately very many Turkish people
and syrians live in multi-story
multi-occupancy high-rise buildings and
and forgive the the Layman's question on
this but uh is only the very best
buildings uh ones that could from around
the world in in the most developed
expert Nations when it comes to
architecture the ones that could
withstand this type of Quake or is the
opposite it's only the the most poorly
built that would collapse
it's very much a mixture of things
because this is a complex earthquake
engineering issue however turkey has got
very good earthquake Engineers it's got
very good building codes what it doesn't
appear to have is decent enforcement of
them it's possible to make quite simple
mistakes that can mean the difference
between survival and pancake-like
collapse for buildings and therefore if
the writing is done buildings will
survive this sort of earthquake they may
be seriously damaged but they're not
going to collapse totally as we have
seen in very many occasions in this
earthquake but also in the last 20 or so
Turkish earthquakes
and and I mean Syria is a slightly
different question of course because of
of uh the the the Civil War that's
ravaged the nation in in recent years
but turkey is is a country where you
would expect uh much higher standards to
have been in place and and I mean I'm
not trying to point fingers here but but
would this be something that after the
fact you would imagine there would be uh
investigations into
well um there's plenty of literature on
the nature of Turkish building and its
deficiencies with respect to earthquakes
I've been reading some of it today and
it is remarkable how in each new
earthquake in this part of the world
exactly the same patterns of damage
occur now they may be larger or smaller
uh depending on the size of the the
amount of shaking the power of the
earthquake itself however if we look at
what is happening now what has happened
today it is very similar in kind to what
happened for example in Izmir in 2021 or
does Jay or ismeet in 1999 when there
were 17 000 deaths in an earthquake uh
hence really nothing new in that respect
I fear I have actually lived in this
sort of building the kind that you can
see uh here in the um photographs and
really I didn't feel safe
and and um what danger I mean there's a
lot of uh rescue workers including from
the UK uh traveling today starting their
work tomorrow what danger are they in of
even without further aftershocks of
buildings collapsing from here
right well we see really two kinds of
rescue I think at the moment we're
probably looking at the professional
kind but we've seen lots of images of
non-professional rescue let's bear in
mind that in the earthquake in Mexico
City in 1985 2.2 Rescuers died per
person rescued and that was because many
or most of the rescues were
non-professional they therefore involved
undue risks on the part of people trying
to rescue one could understand exactly
why they were trying to do so however
you're dealing with large amounts of
very heavy Rubble that are completely
unstable we therefore lead the expertise
the equipment the training and the
discipline to be able to do that
properly unfortunately most
International rescue teams arrive within
the window of time 48 to 72 hours after
the event the golden period is the first
12 hours after which survival times
under Rubble tend to decline very
substantially
a well-engineered building if it
collapses and this in the photograph
here is not a well engineered building
we'll probably leave about 15 Point
space that means that there may be
people alive underneath Professor
forgive me for interrupting we need to
leave it there we've reached the end of
uh the hour the coverage will continue
here on Sky News